ben's the only one that's going to stick
around because ben understands that
uh without him i would just be
committing acts of domestic terrorism
i said that to the girl of whitney's the
girl from cheer you know this this this
white trash rat
that whitney had in her house what do
you think i care
you know this tattooed animal whitney
thinks cheer when he coming sees tears
like a big
can you shut to stop it whitney just
likes poor people and she likes to play
with them like play-doh
so she likes to
she likes to bring them in her hot tub
and she's like
wouldn't it be fun if one day you
weren't desperate
maybe that would be fun huh do you think
that would be
fun i don't worry about anything ever
but i bet you do and i bet the nights
are cold
are they cold are they cold
we'll get in the hot tub and so she has
this
meth head in her hot tub who's a
cheerleader which
come on like competitive cheerleading in
texas like i give a [ __ ]
so i will supposedly it's the most
watched show on netflix i don't give a
[ __ ] everything on netflix suck
the queen's gambit sucks it sucks it's
bad
everything's bad now it's not
good
the chest thing they should make is when
bobby fischer went nuts and went into
jews
we have a fun chess story the day of 9
11
bobby fischer called the radio station
she had gone over to juice
why are we that's a fun chess story of
how
he went to there how he became that
that's a fun chess story
not [ __ ] hey this [ __ ] likes doing
taking pills and
chess who cares
so nothing's good i don't care if it's
the most watched show on netflix what's
the second most watched
the ranch with ashton kutcher and that
other guy
the most watched show on netflix means
[ __ ] to me
i don't care what people do some
idiot who's got swimming around in a
bathtub a sweet tea
and [ __ ] it just longs for a time
that she could see your own foot
is watching people do tumble salts it is
impressed so i care
i think not i think not oh they have a
lot of followers on instagram
i want less followers i want less
followers
because i don't want to feel guilty
because the end of this is heaven's gate
called we go to the hillbob comet and
drink
poison i will get all of you to drink
poison
my point is this i go over to the house
and this this girl who's this i'm sure
she's sweet
she's with some other kid they're all
tattooed they're in decent shape i'm
unimpressed
i'm there because i want food that
whitney will
purchase which i don't i always offer to
buy but she buys and i think that's a
better system
so they're in the hot tub and i go
and and uh one girl says to me and she
goes i really lucked out with my manager
because i lucked out with my manager
because she's like i want to build
businesses around my passions and not
just do random brand deals
she goes i also really am looking for
guidance
i want people to guide me and steer me
in a direction but i don't want to be
controlled i just want guidance
and she goes what would you like to do i
was returning and she was in the hot tub
i looked at her i said
i want to commit an act of domestic
terrorism
do you understand so i'm looking for
someone to help
build a terrorist network around
my passions do you understand and not
just random
brand deals i want guidance
imagine somebody in al qaeda being like
what i like about this organization
is that i don't feel controlled but i'm
given guidance
given guidance by the saudis the c.i.a
bin laden
the girl kind of laughed
cheer no one cares no one gives a [ __ ]
about your shitty lives
i don't care that they put them on
netflix i don't care that uh
uh you know it's a big deal on netflix
because uh there's so much heart these
kids have so much are you they're on
meth
one of them went away for cp yeah child
porn yeah
he's got a lot of heart he's got too
much heart
he's good on with cp
stop glorifying these shitty things that
no one cares about
i'm a competitive cheerleader stop
get grow up and graduate school and go
work at the dairy queen
and make the blizzard good
let's not call it cheer let's call it
people who will make blizzards in five
years
on netflix future blizzard makers of
america
on netflix and there's nothing wrong
with that i respect the blizzard we
might get one later
but whitney's got them over you know and
whitney's like show me your scars show
me the scars of your
of your poverty whitney's pretending
when he's got like nail people coming in
whitney's like
whitney's like this these are the people
that do the nails for uh
there's cardi b right yeah cardi b these
are the people that do the nails for
cardi b
literally as she said that i'm at her
table
and i go like this i go is is there
two marinara sauces or one
i wanted two
and these kids like what i just want to
build businesses around my passions
like what meth
pull her up get the girl up that was on
there she did drugs
that's all right she's a good person we
respect her yes
what did she do she did some crank go to
the mug shot what did she do
there you go what'd she do she's a
little crank
there's nothing wrong with that i
respect that
oh possession of marijuana oh marijuana
all right
well i feel bad now stupid
what else i thought of something good i
thought it was something good
well there's a cp guy as well well he
got a cp
who cares let her smoke
he was over too he's he's like a weird
vegan and the other guy was a
pescetarian
and the other guy goes like this the
other guy goes yeah i'm a pescatarian
what kind of weirdo only eats fish i'm
like i love fish but if you're gonna
take a moral stand
it's ridiculous um
that is a lot of weed what you have
uh a usable quantity in the amount of
two ounces or less
yeah that's not a lot not for these
people
they just smoke weed and go to
whataburger
and we gotta watch it like it's
fascinating because they can do a
somersault
these kids have so much heart
you get this out of here that's cp on
the bottom there he is this guy yeah
ecp he was the fun one he was the fun
one
he was the star of the show cheer
give me a c give me a p
give me a c give me a p
c p
i gotta i gotta sit there and when he's
like you should do a
dance with them it'll be the most shared
video on your instagram i'm like i don't
want to show them up
because number one i'm a better dancer
than they are
here's the reality i'm a professional
dancer i've been schooled in tap
dance ballet hip hop
hip hop jazz jazz is
like you know jazz but hip hop
is is where a bunch of white kids in the
suburbs
have like inflatable boom boxes and
they're like yo yo
yo and they do hip hop hip hop
like this you're fat white woman being
like yeah
like put on like run dmc and they do hip
hop i've
schooled in all these um dances i don't
do as much gymnastics as i do but i'm a
better dancer
modern dance uh irish tip dance
i'm a better dancer so i didn't want to
i don't want to
embarrass them with my ability to dance